okay big news the david pakman show is
now fully fully accepting cryptocurrency
Bitcoin aetherium and litecoin and the
background of this has been we've had
hundreds of people over the last couple
of years say hey David I've got a bunch
of Bitcoin I'm one of these Bitcoin
millionaires that put in a hundred bucks
into Bitcoin at the beginning and now
it's worth a ton
I'd love to contribute but I want to
contribute via Bitcoin and that is now
available to you we had YouTube's ad
pocalypse which crushed our revenue at
the beginning of April I announced
yesterday that our Amazon affiliate link
has been completely and totally shut
down by Amazon and that is another notch
out of our regular revenue so we have
finally done it we can now accept
Bitcoin aetherium and litecoin
I'm gonna put up our addresses on the
screen for both bitkha for all three
Bitcoin etherium and litecoin
but I understand that particularly with
long case-sensitive strings Pat is
trying to memorize these just as a goof
like he used to like to memorize PI and
he's now trying to memorize our Bitcoin
address but you don't have to do that
okay we are now we've set up a page at
david pakman.com slash cryptocurrency
which has all three of our
cryptocurrency addresses that you can
copy and then paste and use those to
send cryptocurrency contributions and
we're also adding our Bitcoin aetherium
and litecoin addresses to the video
descriptions of every single YouTube
video going forward and I'm gonna try to
also get it added to all of our prior
videos so this is a new opportunity if
you've got cryptocurrency and you like
contributing in that way if you like the
privacy aspect of that also this is a
good option for you and you can get all
three of our addresses at david
pakman.com slash crypto currency and
that's ery PTO currency we've already
received yesterday I just mentioned this
very off handedly and we received three
contributions one via litecoin and two
via Bitcoin so check that out david
pakman.com slash cryptocurrency tell
your friends tell your family tell
anybody who will listen